I've been putting this off for a long
time okay I waited long enough it is
time for me to revisit my ranking of the
doctor the actual performers and the
characterization of the doctor from
Doctor Who going from the beginning
right up to the present day now part of
me wanted to push this off even further
wait for Jodie Whittaker but I've waited
long enough and we've got a clean break
and I feel like I can firmly make my
opinion on Capaldi at this point so I am
going to rank my own personal ranking
for the performances and
characterizations of the doctor starting
with number one all the way up through
Capaldi now a couple of things I've done
this before was actually the very first
Doctor Who list I did years ago but
there's two new doctors to add since
then and some of the rankings have
changed in the meantime as I have sort
of gotten a little more distance from
some of my choices and also as I have
come to absorb more classic who than I
had previously now as far as these
rankings go I am not factoring in Big
Finish comic books novels and it's only
the show and I am fully aware that there
are some doctors who have had either
much better representation in terms of
the quality of their work in and things
like Big Finish or have simply had a lot
more and I am starting to get into that
but I am nowhere near steeped enough in
that for it to have it be weighed fairly
so I'm I just have to take it off the
table
so with that established and the last
thing I'm also gonna say cuz and I'm
gonna bring this up again with the
exception of the very bottom slot which
we'll get to in a second I don't think
there is a bad version of the doctor all
of these are good and whoever is your
doctor even if it is my bottom pick that
is fine and you are not wrong because
one of the beautiful things about Doctor
Who is everyone gets to have their
doctor your pick does not have to be
anyone else's you do not have to write
them the way anyone else does this is
just the way I'm gonna write them so
starting at the bottom
um Colin Baker the sixth doctor I can't
imagine anybody's really all that
surprised by this cuz he just they they
had a sort of a confluence of character
trace for him that all fit the doctor
and they all work on paper but something
didn't click so you know he's kind of
grumpy lots of doctors are grumpy he is
arrogant lots of versions of the doctor
are arrogant he has a certain disdain
for humans a lot of them are like that
but I think there's a couple of things
where you can guess that what is
honestly just the look you can't look at
him and take him seriously and the look
is so at odds with the way he's behaving
that it's not like oh isn't that cool
and quirky it's like it just makes no
sense like you can't wrap your head
around that and then in addition to that
at the time he was playing it I just
ending whether this is a fault in him as
a performer or just the way he was being
directed to play the part
I just think Colin Baker lacked the
underlying charm that you needed to to
not have those more grating aspects of
the doctor actually be grading pretty
much every other performer who's played
the doctor had some level of underlying
inherent charm that made some of the
less desirable qualities of the doctor
as a character either you know much
easier to swallow or and sometimes oddly
endearing Kyle Baker was just missing
that little bit of charm and at least in
his time on the TV show I get I've heard
he was great and Big Finish not counting
it so that's the bottom moving up one
spot the war Doctor John Hurt he's got
what technically he's got two because he
showed up a name of the doctor but
effectively he's only got one appearance
and there's nothing wrong with John
Hurt's performance as the doctor there's
just really nothing memorable about it
either there's not a lot that makes him
distinct there's not a lot about him
that you can go oh that's the defining
trait of that doctor I mean even the
Colin Baker doctor had those they
weren't positive defining traits but he
had them this is just very nondescript
and that's doubly odd given that
his setup that we get in with his not
his introduction but his sort of Webber
you see his regeneration is like warrior
make me a warrior and you don't get that
from the performance and I and I do
understand that by the time we see him
in day of the doctor in whatever warrior
Miss he had going his burnt out he's had
enough yo he starts shooting no more
into a wall he's obviously done but it's
again it's just a matter of what you're
telling us about this character and what
we're seeing about them aren't gelling
you tell us warrior nothing we see about
him is reading as warrior I mean former
warrior maybe but then all that tells us
was we're missing a huge bunch of
information and if I limit it to the TV
show yeah he's fine he's inoffensive
he's not particularly memorable next up
on the list William Hartnell the first
doctor and this is actually part of the
reason that I wanted to get this list in
now before the Christmas special comes
up because if and when I tackle this
list again I may need to figure out if
I'm if I count David Bradley towards
William Hartnell's doctor does he
actually need to be ranked separately as
he distinct enough I'd I don't want to
have to address that question and then
when that Christmas episode airs I may
have to so setting that aside looking
exclusively at William Hartnell as the
doctor he took a little bit of time to
kind of get to where I did really enjoy
him because he does start out basically
in grumpy grandpa mode well I mean which
is what he was he did have a little bit
of that twinkle in the eye but it came
more to the forefront as his time as the
doctor went on so that by the time he
finished I think he really was as good
as he was gonna get and it's and he is
lacking some of the qualities I like in
the doctor and in a way that's unfair
because he was the first so you know
people had to distinguish their versions
from his of course more stuff got at it
later but if we're talking personal
preferences he's just a little too
crotchety for my taste but he's he's
still very good I mean you you watch
something like the Dalek invasion of
Earth and he's wonderful
he is really good it's just a lot of his
earlier stuff he just he is that that
overly crotchety character next up on
the list one that I is actually the
personal favorite of a lot of friends of
mine and I'm just gonna shrug and say
they see something I don't and I don't
get it
Peter Davison again he's not bad I mean
we're only my bottom pick was bad so
Peter Davison is good and again he has a
lot of the qualities that I like to see
in the doctor he's a bit emotionally
detached from things but he still it
seems to really go for a sense of
adventure which is nice to see and it's
it's not a bad balance of that but
there's there's a quality that's really
hard for me to define in terms of his
performance that just makes it not quite
click for me and the best way that I can
think to put it is it feels like an act
where you know everything he's doing it
makes sense and the way he reacts the
things I understand but it's it's more
like he isn't really feeling these
emotions but he knows what the correct
emotional response is and he's just sort
of doing that because he knows that's
what's expected but he's not actually
feeling it there's something about Peter
Davison that's slightly detached and
that's different from sort of a sense of
being alien which is something that a
lot of the versions of the doctor that
that I love have and some of them have
it in spades but for some reason with
Davison for me that quality doesn't read
as a leonis it just reads as detached
like in a in a way that doesn't read as
separate from human just in a in
something's not quite fully clicking way
and I think that largely might have just
been equality of the age he was when he
started because there's no hint of what
I'm talking about in something like time
crash where you know he was older I just
he seems more comfortable maybe that's
the thing there's only a couple of his
stories that I've seen work he seemed
really
at peace with the part he seemed III
have to wonder if the weight of the
responsibility of playing this part and
how young he was certainly compared to
most of the other actors who played the
doctor if that just weighed on him a
little bit and affected his performance
and and maybe that's the vibe that I'm
getting but there is something about
that vibe that just throws me off a
little he's still good though
next up Jon Pertwee now I mentioned
charm before you want to talk charm this
man's got charm to spare oh when he's on
he's great especially when he's playing
against Roger Delgado who in my opinion
is the best version of the master I've
done that list before but he's just
wonderful and charming and he's he's
pompous and arrogant but in a way that
like you can't help but just find him
kind of lovable really the only reason
that he doesn't rank way higher on the
list is this was the era where the
doctor was action hero and he was doing
I forget exactly what they got like some
form of interstellar judo and I just
don't like I don't like the doctor just
getting stuck in in a fight and flipping
guys and all that and that honestly that
one specific aspect it does a bit to
bring it down for me and and that's a
shame because otherwise he's really
great in this part so it is it does bum
me out that it is just one aspect of it
of his characterization that doesn't
quite work for me but it's what happens
next up on the list moving our way up
Sylvester McCoy the Seventh Doctor he
was another one that I think his first
season is a bit wonky and because I feel
like the writers didn't quite know what
to do with him yet but once you start to
see the Machiavellian nature of him and
sort of that that Chessmaster
sensibility that he's moving all the
pieces and he knows exactly what he's
doing and that sort of hint of darkness
in his advance planning that you get and
stuff like remembrance of the Dalek or
curse of Fenric and things like that
it's it works really well and McCoy
plays it one
and he cuz he can do the light affable
you know oh you wouldn't take this guy
seriously but then he'll he'll get
quieter I'll just get this look on his
face that you're like oh okay
it's about to get real now and I enjoy
that contrast I think the fact that it
did take basically season for him to
really start getting into that mode is
part of the reason he's not higher up
but I do still like that quality in him
moving up to a spot to number 7 we are
hit the middle of these third team
rankings and it is time for christopher
eccleston he really did grab me pretty
much as soon as he showed up on screen
like right from that moment where he
asks rose her name is it nice to meet
you rose run for your life
and I I was immediately hooked on this
guy I think he is wonderful he's sweet
he's charming but you peel it back to
slightly and you get a sense of just how
damaged he is and you really do get that
sense of just having been through
absolute hell but trying to move on from
it and there's so many great little
moments I love with with Eccleston I
mean that everybody lives is one of my
favorite things in all of Doctor Who I
love that I love when he's there just
throwing information at him about the
city he's just going narrows it down
narrows it down we only have one series
out of him and I feel like as much as I
enjoy and appreciate and identify that
sort of damage that's in him and I
absolutely respect it as a choice for
how to play the character it's not as
much fun for me to revisit as others so
that's sort of why he falls in the
middle I get remember this is all
relative I still love the ones I even
ranked below him I love but it we're
really getting into personal preference
territory now where there are just
certain things about the way that
they're being played that just isn't
exactly what I want to spend with my
doctor at least not for their whole run
which in the case of Eccleston was
unfortunately very brief you still good
and now for the one that had the biggest
move from the last time I did this list
to now that's what I'm probably gonna
have to spend the most time Explo
why and I am dead certain that there was
a lot of people who were just gonna
switch this thing off the minute I say
this but number 6 David Tennant if you
have stuck through and are actually
letting me talk and I aren't just
screaming and banging your response as
to why I'm wrong allow me to explain
first off Tennant last time I did this
list was my number two and Tennant in
many ways is my doctor he is the first
doctor I ever really paid attention to
because first time I ever saw this show
I was on my honeymoon in London I was
scrolling through channels when we had
nothing else to do and I came across the
Satan pit and I saw him and I was
immediately engaged by him I think he is
great he has that sense of adventure
he has terrific chemistry with most of
his cast the smile is awesome when he
goes dark he sells it but when I am
comparing him to the other doctors and
what I'm identifying the things that I
really love about the other doctors
there's there's one specific thing about
Tennant that just I wish it wasn't the
case and that is basically he's too
human and I mean that in terms of his
responses his reactions he reacts to
things too much like I would expect a
human to do as opposed to someone from a
different culture different society
different planet different species to do
there's not a lot of sense of the alien
about him and when it works I love that
sense of alienness in the doctor and
Tenant has that the least I think it's
possibly arguable he doesn't have it at
all now again I'm not saying that is a
bad way to play the doctor I it's
perfectly fine if he is your favorite
he's many people's favorite doctor but
for me and what I like about this
character it's a really key component to
most of the versions of this character
that I really love and he just doesn't
have it and I had to really look in my
heart of hearts when readjusting this
list and this is where he landed number
five
tricked Rosen oh that mischievous
cowardly little imp I really ease so
much of the staples of what we think of
Doctor Who originated with traveling
running as a first response just
bumbling into the situation so that the
people he's around will think he's an
idiot not take him seriously which frees
him up to just you know explore it
they're not paying attention to him
because they don't think him seriously
if he can get all the information that
he needs I love his little pipe I love
his interactions with his companions his
relationship with Jamie especially is
wonderful and he also can can turn that
switch when he gets serious there is uh
there is an intensity in his eyes when
he makes the decision that he is going
to stop what's going on you can there's
something about his face that gets that
but at the same time he never quite
loses that very jovial like he's like
your favorite uncle I agreed for lack of
a better comparison and he just strikes
such a wonderful balance between the
bumbling the fun the the cowardice and
yet still managing to be the hero of the
story moving up to number four and this
is a rather impressive leap considering
I I I am serious that is literally a
short that moved him from his previous
placement on this listen that's Paul
McGann last time I did this list night
of the doctor had not come out so I
could judge him only on the movie and
while he was the best thing about that
movie it was not good and then I saw
night of the doctor and immediately I'm
like I gotta find more of this guy's
stuff and I actually have I have heard
some of his Big Finish about I'm still
really trying to I it may have seeped
him but I'm really trying to not count
that towards this ranking because I do
think just based off night of the doctor
you watch the the heroic sense and like
you get like tells you so much about his
version of the doctor in those
what is it seven minutes with the way he
shows up the way he interacts with this
one with the way he's willing to die
trying to save a woman he just met who
hates him the way he responds to the The
Sisterhood where he's just they bring
him back to life and he's completely
dismissive of the whole thing and yet
you can tell that as dismissive of he is
and as much as he's trying to maintain
fun that he knows how serious everything
is and he knows the situation he just
wishes that it was fun and he remembers
when it was and he wishes it was that
again that's the vibe I get off just in
those seven minutes and I think he's
worth the bump up into the top five into
the number four spot just based off that
along he's really good
okay top three we get to my previous
number one pick Matt Smith
I still love me some Matt Smith very
much you want to talk about the alien he
brought the sense of alien back after
ten it's much more human doctor and you
know that sense and I know for some
people it just it just reads as overly
quirky I get that but for me it's it's
it's wonderful and it's fun and it's
endearing and just watching him bounce
around with the PO tie or the Fez or the
Stetson and that he's able to any he
brings in a lot of elements from a lot
of different doctors and that he will do
sort of the the bumbling in but he does
have that darkness and he has these
wonderful interactions and he manages
like I said that sense of alienness in
the way he responds to things that is
not exactly how a human would respond
but but manages to avoid that sort of
just detachment that I felt with Davison
and I mention it before I'm probably
partially biased because Matt Smith is
my age so I think for that reason I
probably on a personal level connected
with him probably better than anybody
else especially during his run I just I
had an absolute ball with him but we are
getting up into the top two and you know
if you've been keeping track you've got
a checklist you know who's left so when
I tell you number two you
number one is but let me just get
through it anyway so number two
to my surprise Peter Capaldi and
surprise for two reasons one he is the
most recent doctor and given that last
time I did this list was when Matt Smith
was still the doctor and he made my
number one I am open to the possibility
that I might be prisoner of the moment
and I just fall in love with whoever the
doctor is at the time that's a
possibility I guess I'll know that for
certain next time I rewrite these but
the other reason this is a surprise for
me is that he didn't completely start to
click with me until his second season
and actually his the way he played the
doctor shifts over all three series that
he's in and some could say that's
inconsistency for me worked and it felt
like a journey for his character because
you've got that first series where he is
he's very grumpy that this is the start
of a whole new regeneration cycle he
shouldn't even have this life and he's
grouchy and crotchety and he doesn't
quite heat he's losing his connection
with the companion that he had already
been with for a while and you sense him
like he's he knows what the doctor
should be these trying maybe a little
too hard the second series that he's
then is when we get the sunglasses and
the hoodie and the guitar playing and I
know for some people some people I heard
people say it's like it's like he's
going through a midlife crisis and I
would say yes but I enjoyed watching
that because first of all I think Peter
Capaldi can just sell that and he did
and it made the doctor more fun but he
also went so far into it that it did
lead a little bit like a midlife crisis
like between his first and second series
he found the fun again and then was like
oh yeah this and he went a little too
hard into and then in his final series
he got that happy medium between the two
and I could I liked him better every
series that he showed up and by the time
he was done I
it's almost tragic to me that he's
leaving he has come to embody so much
and so much
aspects of what I love about the doctor
in different amounts depending on when
he was playing the part and again some
people can read that as inconsistency in
the characterization or the writing but
this the sequence in which the different
sort of aspects of the characterization
happened to me felt like a proper and
believable journey for the doctor as a
character and we don't see the doctor
changing grow all that often it happens
a little bit in a couple for a couple of
the doctors but I feel it is most
pronounced here and for me that works so
that does mean the number one spot Tom
Baker and this was a move that came with
my I'm getting more immersed into
classic whoo and uh-huh I talked about
that sense of alienness you know I
brought up with Matt Smith you this guy
from another planet no question when
this man tells you he's not from Earth
you believe it in a heartbeat he is so
perfect to play an alien in the same way
that like David Bowie was when he did
the man who fell to earth is just you
just look at the guy and you listen to
him darling like oh yeah no he's he's
not from around here so he has that
wonderful sense of alienness and he has
a wonderful sense of childishness but
not in an immature way just in a not
having become too jaded way and I think
that might be one of the things about
new who that I think gets overplayed is
how jaded the doctor is and just this
sweet spot of the Fourth Doctor and the
fact that he has lines like what's the
point of being a grown-up if you can't
be child you sometimes the things the
fact that he even has things like that
to say just immediately speaks to me
it's like this yes yes this guy I want I
want to travel with you I want to be
right by your side I want to see
everything you do I want to just feed
off your vibe and your your mellow and
just everything about Tom Baker I cannot
fault a single aspect too
the only thing I can possibly say is he
played the part for just a little too
long and during his last series there's
a couple of episodes where you like you
you kind of get that you look a little
tired but like that's it he did it for
maybe a series too many but other than
that for me I can find no fault with Tom
Baker's doctor just simply phenomenal
and in my estimation at this point in my
life until I rank them again at some
point down the line inevitably but right
now my favorite choice for an actor to
play the role of the doctor on Doctor
Who if you stuck with me this far that
means that I didn't tick you off too
much I hope with my ranking whatever
your thoughts are and your own ranking
please by all means share try and keep
things polite be respectful of people's
thoughts and rankings and everything
else but whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher I am also one half
of the punch like a girl podcast which
will be on the fire and water Network
starting in October and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]